[Musique]
je crache dans les airs il l'attrape
doucement dans mon saladier merci
à toi depuis l'effacement de l'outrage à
la pudeur du code pénal en 1994 les
hommes ont le droit de se balader torse
nu à condition que le maire n'est pas
pris un arrêté spécifique l'interdisant
sur une zone bien définie donc c'est le
maire qui prend des arrêtés de police où
il va indiquer les tenues qui sont
correctes il y a des amendes qui vont de
15 euros à 60 euros environ car la
poupée inventait en 1959 je vous
attendais bonsoir ma chérie a commencé
sa carrière comme femme au foyer avec
vous ça me changera les idées les femmes
elles tombent sous le coup de la loi
contre l'exhibition sexuelle elle risque
15.000 euros d'amende et un an de prison
ai-je le droit de conduire en tongue
depuis quelques jours en Iran cette
vidéo est devenue virale sur les réseaux
sociaux
on y aperçoit une femme non voilée
interpellée en pleine rue par une femme
ou hijab présuméement de la police des
mœurs
démantelé au plus fort de la
contestation la police des mœurs s'est
de retour dans la rue leur cible des
femmes jugées trop émancipées selon le
régime et qui ne respecte pas les codes
vestimentaires strictes tu pars en
vacances
depuis Noël
c'est sérieux non attends mais elle est
pleine ou pas ah non
mais arrête c'est une blague dedans
à 30 ans 7 habitants de Téhéran qui
préfèrent rester anonyme vit dans
l'angoisse permanente mais elle refuse
de céder
pour nous les femmes ce n'est pas depuis
deux jours mais depuis des mois que nous
avons peur et que nous sommes stressés
mais malgré tout nous continuons de ne
pas obéir mais très vite Barbie devient
tactile hôtesse de l'air vétérinaire ou
astronaute elle apprend plus de 250
métiers la volonté de sa créatrice
j'espère que Barbie va vivre longtemps
en reflétant toujours les changements de
la société de nouvelles accusations
contre Nicolas Bedos le parquet de Paris
a annoncé hier avoir ouvert une enquête
pour violer agression sexuelle trois
femmes ont déposé plein de contrôle le
réalisateur deux d'entre elles dénoncent
des violences sexuelles qui ont eu lieu
en 1999 pour lune et 2017 pour l'autre
son avocat avait décrit un geste
accidentel et selon Médiapart c'est ce
terme qui a fait réagir plusieurs femmes
trois d'entre elles ont déposé plainte
l'une d'elles est comédienne elle accuse
le réalisateur de l'avoir violé chez lui
en 19
99 après une soirée entre amis je sais
pas une blague
c'est bon j'ai compris
dans ma tête c'est ça
tout était faux il y avait pas ce
feeling il y avait pas ce petit truc
selon ses propos tu serais parti en
vrille il aurait complètement changé de
comportement il lui aurait demandé avec
insistance de monter dans sa chambre
elle aurait refusé elle aurait pris ses
affaires pour partir et là d'après son
récit il l'aurait plaqué contre le mur
l'aurait attrapé par la gorge et lui
aurait dit mais tu te prends pour qui tu
es pas Catherine Deneuve j'ai vu
quelqu'un derrière moi ou pas on va
remettre les images au ralenti j'ai vu
quelqu'un derrière moi
alors regardez elle arrive derrière moi
regardez elle arrive et elle se rabat
c'est excellent cette vidéo a été vue
plus de 5 millions de fois sur Twitter
alors du coup là je suis à Saint-Maximin
devant basic-fit un homme s'approche
d'elle
il lui propose 100 euros en échange d'un
rapport sexuel
non non j'ai jamais dit non non j'avais
dit ça j'ai très bien il faut respecter
tout après plusieurs refus non mais non
non l'homme insiste elle lui demande de
partir les plus belles naissances Anaïs
et vraiment j'en parle en connaissance
de cause les plus belles naissances sont
celles qui qui naissent du fruit de
l'amour pas du fruit de la magouille
ça vraiment c'est bon
c'est le fruit de l'amour je n'en sais
rien
tu peux t'aimer sans faire des enfants
aussi vous êtes chelou non je suis non
donc bouge je savais pas comment réagir
et je me suis dit à tout moment il a un
couteau donc j'ai préféré rester calme
j'étais entre deux voitures donc tout le
moment
je me suis dit il a un couteau il
m'agresse ou je suis resté calme et puis
j'ai attendu je trouve ça un peu
un peu triste de se faire la tête juste
pour une histoire de chanson
pardon j'ai bien entendu c'est quoi
cette histoire vous ne vous parlez plus
depuis 5 ans à cause d'une chanson
vous êtes musicien c'est ça on est avant
tout artiste tous les deux tu es prêt un
petit roulement de tambour quand même
pour le
3 4
[Musique]
j'adore ce jeu enfin j'adore parce que
je gagne ouais sinon je déteste j'avais
envie de faire une autre version de coco
et Romain il m'a dit non qu'il y avait
pas trop envie qui était pas trop motivé
et moi je dis ben si c'était pas motivé
bah c'est pas grave je vais le faire
avec Angélique je vais le faire avec ma
femme sa copine elle a tout simplement
repassé derrière que ce que je l'avais
fait avec mon frère et ça je l'ai pas
supporté et c'est ça qui a tout brisé
parce que le con de base donc vous
faites tous partie autour de la table
qui passe qui passe sa vie sur son
portable y compris quand on bouffe en
tête-à-tête et à regarder le coup
d'après peut se détacher des avis quoi
est-ce que vous pouvez aller manger un
dans un restaurant parce que vous avez
envie de manger dans ce restaurant
dans lequel je ne veux pas rentrer
[Musique]
des semaines et des jours qui passent
sans toi
toi mon frère
pardonne mes erreurs
moi j'aimerais qu'une seule seconde
je vois